um this is a bunch of rules it's a bunch
of rules
um properties is like a fancy way for
rules
uh and i hate memorizing rules
memorizing rules sucks
but if you remember things like say
like say the chain rule okay and the
channel is not such a bad
rule to memorize because really what
it's doing is it's giving you shortcuts
um rules like chain rule they just
basically are
shortcuts so shortcut is a better word
than rule right
so when you look down this page it looks
intimidating because
you know most of the internet google
location is still pretty new to you okay
but i hope this becomes to you shortcuts
that will let you do stuff faster than
you would have done otherwise okay
so let's march down the page and see if
we can explain what these things are
number one that first property that's
just the definition okay you guys have
seen that already so you might like to
write
definition next to property number one
okay
property number two there's not so much
to it
it's simply getting the fact that i
mentioned before that the
x and the dx or the w and the dw and the
z and the d
and so on right in a definite integral
the letter is inconsequential it doesn't
matter what letter is because
it will instantly get replaced by a
number once you start to evaluate this
thing
okay and that's why we call the dummy
variable okay
now when we start to move further down
the list okay
i want you to put an asterisk next to
three four five and six
the asterisk is for us to prove them
okay now what we're gonna do is
uh we're gonna go back to the definition
you know number one
to prove three four five and six many of
them will be intuitive
especially because if you have a look at
say number five okay number five
uh what's there on the left-hand side
you're taking a definite integral
right and you've got two functions
inside there that you're actually
integrating okay
now on the right-hand side you've got
the two functions and they're separate
you can integrate them separately okay
now
that's just like how we work with
differentiation right if i gave you
something like this
i said look here's one big function and
i want you to differentiate it okay
at least mentally probably what you're
doing is you're just separating them
and you're treating them as two
completely independent things right you
do this one and you get your value
and then you do this one you get that
value okay
so being that we can do this with
differentiation and integration is the
inverse of differentiation you have to
expect that you would do the same thing
that's what property five is about
but i want us to do more than just say
oh it's like differentiation so we ought
to be able to do it
i want us to go back to the definition
and prove these things okay
so let me walk you through how you would
go about doing this rigorously let's do
number three today
okay now the sheets a little bit naughty
and forgets to mention this it kind of
assumes
because k is usually a constant right
but you might like to put it on the side
there
because what we're explaining here is
just like with differentiation
if i'm differentiating a function with a
constant coefficient
i can just take that constant
coefficient out in the front and ignore
it and just whack it onto the amp okay
and it's the same deal with integration
so how would i go about proving this
okay well
as with usual proofs you pick a side
right and then i want to go from
left to right okay so well
which side should we pick does it matter
i feel like they're both pretty similar
let's go with that
okay so let's evaluate this this is well
let's write it down first
according to like the definition of what
integration is okay a definition
what's going to happen is that you're
going to have k times now
what happens to this the process of
integrating i don't know what this
f is right i'm just going to get the
primitive function yeah
so inside these square brackets okay
i'm going to get k times the primitive
that's okay right now remember i don't
need to worry about the constant
because once i evaluate these two
boundaries okay the constants would
cancel each other out
yeah okay now what does this mean i
actually have to evaluate these right
so this is k f b do your upper bound
first
and then take the difference with your
lower bound
that's all okay all right now
i know it's pretty trivial in some ways
but how do i get from here
to here right well the difference is
that this k is out the front it doesn't
appear twice
just once right so therefore if i
factorize
sorry now what i've got
this in here by definition go back to
property number one
okay by definition that's my right hand
side here
okay that's k times the integral from a
to b
of that function suppose if you wanted
to
at this point you can say where
f is the primitive
of lowercasing
but that's it you just sort of uh it's
just like a trigger identity right you
take something
you unwind a little bit you simplify and
then you tidy it back up with some kinds
of definitions or identities that you
know okay